okay a final game for today above the
fee the master from Spain okay let's try
something else ok let's go for Sicilian
okay at least it's an open the Sun play
them not sure can our pods and variation
it's got many names I think FY am
oh this is so unusual to treat the night
without being provoked somehow should
help like a little bit
ok let's go before
okay to Castle castle at some point but
ok but made pretty good progress on the
queenside and can also play this in one
move plus e five now which looks normal
you cannot capture and just threatened
to take here I have an ID for
should be fairly nice for black
but this could be a three
let's open up the position directly
I also you to keep in mind that I can
sometimes we capture and plate you fall
not sure what he should play here maybe
capture CB and then a three but this
invites the sacrifice on a three look
some pretty bad already
no idea
let's notice connection isn't it let's
check quickly I'm still connected and he
also so he just doesn't have any idea
how to how to continue
wow it's down to one minute okay so what
now it cannot move Roxy one this is so
because of the hanging bishop
hmm
yeah I suppose so many good moves here
of course I could simply take on a three
but I don't think that this is really
technically winning let's bring a rope
to c8 see what movie will come up with
94
couldn't be six maybe
okay maybe this some threatens
discoveries
just Roxy five Bishop c5
okay now Bishop a 62 d three
yeah looks very ugly okay let's grab
this oh I didn't think this was possible
it should be three yeah
hmm yeah I can just take the night or
take here this a mate just take the
night white resides oh there he was a
provisional rated so maybe its rating
wasn't at higher but well still a feeder
master so yes was a huge opening success
i guess but it was very very helpful
here I think this is already small
mistake because some very often black
plays Knight b6 in order to push the
night back to be three and then retreats
to see seven so I gained a tempo on
lions on this this type and the second
thing was I could get my monthly going
here without playing d6 and then play d
five in one move so I think I gained
really a couple of tempe here compared
to normal lines and this already um it's
pretty difficult for white to say the
least maybe it's already really bad yeah
thanks for watching